this is a few moments after roadside
bomb went off in jalalabad
one of the many attacks that have
targeted the city in the last week
mostly carried out by isil in
afghanistan
the armed group known as the islamic
state of horusan is a regional affiliate
of isil holasand is the historical term
for the region that includes modern-day
afghanistan
it was behind the attack at kabul
airport last month which killed
170 people including 13 us troops
established in 2015 the armed group
considers the taliban its enemy and has
vowed to spread its own ideology
for the bihola mujahid the taliban's
spokesman it's just a matter of time
before isil in afghanistan is defeated
when we took over the country last month
some isil k operatives moved to kabul
and jalalabad we launched an operation
in kabul and arrested many
another operation is underway in
jalalabad we're hunting down those who
are sowing chaos and those who are
behind the recent blasts we've caught
dozens so far
on the streets of kabul taliban fighters
have established checkpoints they are
searching for suspects
the group praises itself for restoring
stability across the country
his fighters are on alert to prevent any
blast or suicide bomb attack in the
capital
last year the taliban agreed indo had to
prevent armed groups from using
afghanistan as a base now the u.s and
others in the international community
want the taliban to deliver on its
promise
foreign fighters affiliated with al
qaeda left afghanistan we don't see them
here anymore but as far as isil is
concerned its fighters are mainly
afghans who embraced a radical ideology
we're doing our best to stop them
clamping down on al qaeda and isil could
pave the way for international
recognition for taliban
and convince the biden administration to
unfreeze billions of dollars in afghan
reserves held in the us
the taliban is under mounting pressure
to restore stability and security but
the attacks in jalalabad raise many
questions about whether its leaders will
be able to push back against iceland's
al qaeda affiliates in afghanistan these
armed groups remain washington's biggest
concern after his true pull out last
month
al jazeera kabul